et tu sais comme jeudi dans un de mes
poèmes et quand je partirai je
m'envolerai par des signaux montagne en
tout en laissant mon coeur mais
regardant mon âme je me poserai est
posée sur un écran hd le piano les yeux
pleins de larmes
je vais les hommes détruire mon paradis
ouais ça c'est mon paradis et la barbe a
jeté 10 sur le monde les fous c'est le
monde est fou c'est l'autre côté du
golfe et c c'est la ville c'est les gens
qui courent à voir c'est pour moi ce
monde des fous pendant ce temps là aux
portes du désert des agriates dans le
maquis corse
joe villa où plus personne n'habite à
quelques 30 minutes de bateau de la
première ville il a 77 ans et voilà à
quoi ressemble la vie qu'ils mènent
depuis plus de dix ans je vais te
montrer la vue qu'on a là je vais te
montrer mon salon d'été la semoy c'était
magnifique
jamais jamais ses tableaux que je vois
c'est pas et je comprends pas qu'on a
détruit cette incurie jeu qu'on me
compare je comprends pas du tout j'ai
quitté le mans le défaut en 2010 ouais
c'est douze ans maintenant que je mène
cette vidéo est un homme parce que c'est
une lutte tout le monde je te veux dire
souvent les gens me disent je suis là
avec mon tu fais élus et à la solitude
qu'elle pèse pas trop tu rigoles ou quoi
celui tu ne me pèse pas du tout pas du
tout pas du tout je me régale je vais
rarement après j'aime j'aime j'aime
avoir des biberons de l'été bon j'aime
la fête je suis pas sauvage bien en
dollars eh bien
voilà qu'à la douche et d'été bien voir
là tu te douche là tu vois rien qui
collera tu peux passer des heures 1
une vue voit que va être bien
par contre il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
me dit hein qu'est ce que j'aimerais
mener une vie comme comme tulameen est
gênante tu es trop jeune bout de deux
mois tu vas te faire chier tu vas
rentrer là cette année j'ai planté 100
pieds de vigne je compte faire mon vin
est un pilier est au dessous je le
potager je suis arrivé c'était que du
maquis qui voit ses propriétés
appartient à une amie et à moi je me
suis installé à comme ça le petit char
est un petit truc tu voyais encore
quelques faits 28 ans là je viens de
planter trois quatre pieds de courgettes
l'ag des artichauts qu on ramassera mois
de novembre l'ag des fraisiers que
monsieur italien cogérer solaire parce
que bon je fonctionne tout au solaire 1
et l arrivée des réserves je risquais
rien je retourne pour les fêtes de fin
d'année pour moi mes enfants et ma
petite fille je passe quatre jours
noël est premier dans ce roman là n'ont
jamais j'ai vite je peux pas ma compagne
à un tue un jeu pour comme je te lis je
pourrais vivre en autarcie tout en la
respectant mode pascal avoir moi je suis
chasseur et pêcheur c'est juste pour mon
soutien ma cabane pour moi je suis pas
un ermite voir je suis quelqu'un j'aime
la solitude je me suis retiré ici parce
que justement j'en avais marre de ce
monde de dingue mais
et voilà mais je vous serai du monde je
prends un plat et je veux dire vraiment
ici comme je dis toujours il n'ya pas de
porte
ce qu'ils viennent ils sont les
bienvenus ouah l'essentiel c'est quand
ils partent qu'ils me disent pas merci
mais qu'ils soient contents pour moi
c'est le merci con mais n'empêche que
quand même un ermite
il n'a pas les réseaux sociaux connais
j'ai je veux dire gg canalsat g3 bon
quand on vit ici
ici tout seul tu sais les rêves j'en
arrive il est rare que je me souviens
numéraire se souvient armand de mes
rêves mais bon c'est du réel souvent lui
rêve de nanars il faut que je lave ou
mischa mais shawn et t'éloigner pas il
faut avoir un peu ses facilités de de
s'émerveiller devant les choses et parce
que j'en aie pas c'est moi je vois ici
quand il débarque son bateau au lieu de
regarder ce qui l'environnent
l'environnemment ils ont les téléphones
ils font des photos ils font des séries
le met dans sa poche
tu regardes pose-t-on repose toi c'est
là tu vois le soir je les sens quand les
bateaux sont partis il était je vais
pêcher sur le coin à la daurade
c'est ça et comme je te dis libertis à
ne plus avoir de contraintes ou pu avoir
d'obligation n'est pas à vendre compte à
qui que ce soit on me des comptes à qui
que ce soit elle pour avoir peur du
qu'en dira-t-on de mener sa vie
ce fonds d'avoir attaché d'importance et
le regard que les autres peuvent
apporter surtout je m'en fous bien je
suis moi je suis ni mieux n'est plus
mauvais qu'un autre chez normal